hello and welcome back to this video
playing Shiro not sure okay um that's
unconventional yeah so if I can get the
whole center I will take it it should be
quite quite nice okay
Johnny I can't just develop but opening
play like that always hmm
is he getting away with this somewhat
yarn might be t7m meds i mean it's not
good for black budgets it's not lost
just trying to make it difficult for
black to develop a known IBD 7 now
really okay
last time I checked the night nights are
better on GA idiom okay how is he ever
going to develop here it's going to be
interesting this is this is a real
upside of playing 1.e4 as opposed to
like an idea 3 on with one or so if if
black plays some bad moves you're going
to be better after 93 as well but if
black plays a really awful stuff against
efore they just get totally annihilated
yeah I mean here this is going to be
ugly a very very likely ugly okay so
yeah now we're already entering the
world of world of heard him
or is it a world of pain in the big
lebowski I only watched the English
version once I think this is a a little
bit like Philidor
sorry like Murphy in the in the Opera
game the idea
so take on the seven or take only five
yeah it's about what good sorry
it's both good I mean night it's seven
as soon as possible I take these six and
win basically everything
um yeah whoo could be seven huh its
Queen f7 made blacks got just one
spycheck pill before it's over
yeah it cannot cannot play the opening
like that it just doesn't work I mean it
black black it seems like he wanted to
put up some sort of fitted or setup this
is really quite solidly done with this
yeah the end game it's not very
dangerous young like him you know this
is not something that ya yield slides
much so we will usually go here on 92
and then you get this formation this way
he allows me to go F for which of course
I happily playing and now Bishop g4 you
know that will surrender the bishop and
it's the next step because you cannot
keep the peace damn
yeah take take it should be seven and
now of course g4 I know nothing slow
please yeah
and what's the move what's the move now
you basically have to keep this Square
open for the night to retreat but I mean
you see that the engine is on plus two
under so it's really fun smallish there
but it's yeah there's no space I mean
you can so now I'm here here H for
something or long castles it's dreadful
I mean White has an attack already and
there is no counter plane and here here
we're talking about that you cannot play
simply b5 I think what I did was just
one one way to do it the the drawback of
this move is Queen d7 whether the engine
plays this and just wants to punish
black here with with slow moves but here
it was just too attractive too
to not play Cisco it's like it's just
completely toasted and it's all wrong
you know if you want to play a setup
like that and that it's not so bad I
mean if you can keep the center but have
the pawn back on f2 this is a fairly
solid position I mean I have played the
fully dorm once in a while I recently
tried on a recently yeah earlier this
year like in February or something I
tried this and my opponent exchanged on
e5 for the young feet massa
and we played this recording to an
ending quite quickly I have prepared to
play this and I think it's all right
okay I mean it's not it's not something
overwhelming for white white has a
slight advantage as he should have here
with more space but it's quite quite
playable but you have to do it in this
movement and don't allow air form okay
thanks for watching